[Music]
after the rather disappointing but
financially worthwhile theatrical
release of wonder woman 1984
there's already news about the planned
sequel plans for third part do not seem
to have been made dependent on box
office success
but on the phenomenal streaming ratings
at hbo max
as the warner media responsible andy
farcell confirms
wonder woman 1984 exceeded expectations
in every respect after its release
and it doesn't appear that this trend
will change incidentally the
announcement of wonder woman 3 also
marks the return of leading actress gal
gadot as well as director and
screenwriter patty jenkins
especially the latter could surprise one
or the other because
in the hbo max dispute between the
filmmakers and warner brothers
she was rather on the side of the
filmmakers she's also already in the
middle of production on star wars rogue
squadron which is no small project
either
when exactly one roman 3 is going to be
released is still completely unclear
but at least cinemagos can already look
forward to the release
let's move to the biggest news of the
year for us a project we've been working
on in secret daily for
the past three years and into which we
poured more heart and soul than in
any news ever at kino check after
countless lines of code
in years of invested lifetime it is with
great pride that we are happy to
announce we are now
online and directly accessible for you
at kinocheck.com
the website is completely new and has
been launched bilingually
any content like news trailers clips or
originals
can be viewed in english as well as
german under keynotejack.com
or alternatively at kinotech.de
when we first started our small german
channel on youtube about 8 years ago we
had no idea how incredibly big this
project would become one day
the fact that today with a team of more
than 10 people we are running europe's
largest movie entertainment network on
which
millions of people gather information
about the latest movies
day after day was not even conceivable
to us in our dreams
it makes us very proud and you make us
proud and with our ad-free website we
want to say
thank you on the website you will know
always have the ability to see the
latest movie information
exclusive trailer premieres current
movie releases the most important news
plus
actually intelligent movie
recommendations based on our
own developed algorithm naturally the
website works on all major devices so
you can access it either from home or on
the go
please everyone feel personally invited
to drop by and make yourselves
comfortable
kinocheck.com is now your go-to place
for all things movies
[Music]
playstation fans heads up as sony
picture ceo tony vincy carrera announced
in an interview
10 sony projects based on popular video
games are currently in production to be
more precise
there are supposed to be 3 movies and 7
series
of which only the movie of uncharted and
the series for the last of us
have been named so far of course this
leaves even more room for speculation
since many brands like god of war
ghost of tsushima and horizon zero dawn
and the ever popular sackboy offer
enough material for a series or a movie
which game would you like to see adapted
into a film
just let us know in the comments slowly
but surely the release of mad max furios
is getting closer as variety reports the
prequel around the eponymous character
is now said to have got the green light
as well as a u.s theatrical release on
june 23
2023 after the acclaimed blockbuster mad
max fury road it is now time to tell the
prequel story of furiosa who will not be
portrayed by charlize theron this time
the role will be played by the witch
actress alia tayla joy who is currently
the talk of the town thanks to the
netflix series
the queen's gambit behind the camera is
by the way mad max creator george miller
who provides the appropriate production
of the cast members besides taylor joy
include chris hemsworth and yaya
abdulmatin ii
the responsible studio warner brothers
also made headlines since only a
theatrical release has been announced
for furiosa
this comes as a surprise because the
studio recently announced that it would
release all of its 2021 films
simultaneously on hbo max and in
theaters and many assumed that this
could also become a business strategy
beyond the end of the year
so here's hoping that warner's
controversial method is really limited
to 2021
the expected release date of mad max
furiosa is on june 23
2023 a european release date will surely
follow soon
more than two years have passed since
the book adaption of the science fiction
bestseller
ready player one the dystopian story
about the virgin world of oasis set in
2045 was written by ernest cline who
already gained
fabulous reviews back in 2011 with the
novel's release
so klein also confirmed a few days ago
that a possible film adaption was still
in an early phase of development
primarily due to the partially closed
movie theaters
the story of the prequel could similarly
to the already published book revolve
less around weight watts and more around
the story of oasis founder james
halliday and octon morrow
thus rather putting the focus on the
origins of oasis
however the sequel has not been as well
received as the first book
but klein is rather unimpressed by that
so it is safe to say that nothing has
been finalized yet but given the very
solid financial success of ready player
one
we can definitely expect a sequel the
iconic franchise around the blue
hedgehog can't be kept down
paramount pictures announced his second
part shortly after the release of sonic
the hedgehog the popular character tales
already appeared in a mid-credit scene
the orange yellow fox and good friend of
sonic was all along in search of his
blue buddy who was hiding
from his enemies first introduced in the
video game in 1994 the short beat
hedgehog who has also become famous for
the ugandan knuckles mean
already became a fan favorite back then
due to his cool demeanor the skilled
climber could therefore also play a role
in the sequel
alongside tales there's already a
favorite for the voiceover in the film
community namely none other than dwayne
johnson besides johnson names like
samuel jackson and chris
rock are also circulating as dubbing
actors for the animated characters
however nothing has been officially
confirmed yet a release can be expected
on april 8th
[Music]
2022
[Music]
you